So now we have a fun game
against a teammate of mine
who doesn't know that he's playing against me,
yes, it's always difficult because we
always knew each other's openings,
okay, I don't have a specific idea yet what
I'm going to do, let's see what
happens, aha, play G3  Well, I'm going to play
something that I don't normally
play, aha,
well, let's see, maybe we'll go
into a kind of Agel
structure. What's
funny is that I play the variant with
white
knight D5. Is that a threat?
Yes,
okay, I'll prevent it  I
prefer it like this now the question is whether white
D5 is
threatening here, maybe
the direct move B5 B5 is interesting because then I
take take knight B5 queen B7
is structurally certainly
desirable but looks a bit
dangerous with the cline I'll do it
anyway  So of course that gives me a
very nice field here.
I had some nice ideas on B4. I'll just play B4
so that I can easily play knight D5.
Then his bishop on B2 is
really no adornment, but the
knight D5 is all the better, yes, well knight
F4 would of course  now really
liquidate the knight but of course the
structure is also very
weak I could still play queen C6
okay first of all A5 to support the B4
yes the knight obviously goes
to the laces on d5 so that he
wants to swap it, I understand that
too, I have bishops  G5 knight D5
bishop D2 knight C7 bishop C1 yes,
that's a good thing, so we take
away F4 and rely on the good
pawn structure so now I'll do
bishop F6 to prevent white from
perhaps moving quickly D5, yes okay and
now A4 on d5  I can then take it and
play tower A2,
I think, and white is in a somewhat
unpleasant pin,
well that's very unpleasant for
white, the Zumbi 1 is the only one that does
n't give up any material yet and of course it's
terribly passive. I
can also just do D5  hit and
white still can't
move anything I would almost expect that
bishop would just come F6 to
try something, I do
n't know exactly what yet but
t B1 is a move that you do
n't really
want to make, well probably there wasn't a
big one
alternatively, now maybe he's trying
to unleash it with tower E2,
so tower E8 isn't an
unreasonable
move anyway, yes, but I can now ah,
I can't play runner C3 because
then it hits
mhm, I can do something else
cleverly and I
'd like to have an air hole
He still can't
do much, I'll just say
H6,
yes it's really an ugly
position. White can practically
not pull at all because of the binding, so
without
losing material, although I can see that especially in this
position he could really be bishop C1
or  play something like that, no, and that would
work, I didn't even
see it, yes, well, it's of course
also good for Black after that. I've already
won in pawns and am
actively standing, for example, I could take and then
play bishop C3, yes, that's good, so
go to bishop C1, rook D2  Bishop
D2 Bishop C3 If he then takes it, I'll have
time later to cover it with D4. The
pawn goes so well, it almost goes through,
and it's also very good for
Black